avec ces dikaba journaliste écrivain
spécialiste des question sécuritaire au
sahel
bonsoir à vous c'est dikaba vous est
aussi coauteur d'un ouvrage de fond sur
boko haram
ce nouveau kidnapping massive des
colliers il intervient un peu plus de
six ans après celui de chiba qu'on s'en
souvient dans l'état de borno l'état de
borno c'est là qu'est née la secte
islamiste boko haram
cette fois ça c'est cette fois on voit
qu'il est une extension dans l'état de
katsina
c'est une région qui était quand même
assez épargné ce que cela veut dire que
même si beaucoup haram a changé de chef
l'insecte elle reste très active elle
étend son influence
oui il est évident que votre âme à la
présence kidnapping de masse a voulu
montrer que en dépit de coûts qui ont
été portés et des divergences internes
le mouvement reste très actif il garde
encore une capacité opérationnelle
parce que pour monter une opération de
cette envergure enlevé 3 144 enfants à
la fois il faut de la logistique il faut
une organisation quasi militaire et boko
haram en faisant ce tact a voulu
apporter la démonstration du compteur à
ceux qui pensaient que le mouvement
était totalement affaibli
cela dit je pense qu'il faut plutôt
inscrire cette action dans un cadre
d'opportunités et non une ambition
territoriale parce que quand vous savez
territorialement boko haram a perdu
beaucoup de a perdu beaucoup y compris
dans son fief traditionnel qui est
l'état du borno
je ne pense pas que il est une ambition
d'extension territoriale
il s'agit d'un coût d'opportunité d'une
opération d'opportunités qui s'est
présentée et le mouvement a saisi cette
opération pour montrer qu'il a encore
très actifs alors vous dites une
opération d'opportunités justement
comment vocaux haram exploite ce
kidnapping
oui le kidnapping est une coopérative de
boko haram
vous avez bien rappeler que 1 avril 2014
boko haram a enlevé des filles haribo
dans un internat une bonne partie des
finances
jamais été retrouvé ensuite il y avait
un autre enlèvement spectaculaire à
chiba et cet enlèvement avait conduit à
des négociations et les filles ont pu
être libérés boko haram procède à ces
enlèvements
parce que une partie des personnes
enlevées et mobiliser comme combattant
unes aux autres partis notamment les
jeunes filles et les jeunes garçons sont
pyschologiquement travailler pour
devenir de bombes humaines pour aller
commettre des opérations kamikazes il le
sort réservé à ceux justement qui ne
sont pas libérés ah oui le sort leur est
plus que tragique parce que nous avons
documenté dans le cadre de l' ouvrage
que vous avez occupé et que vous avez
évoqué à l'antenne les pratiques
internes de boko haram qui sont des
pratiques fait des violences inouïes
d'embrigadement de souffrance
particulièrement les femmes sont
exploités sexuellement sont à la merci
des combattants et c'est pour cette
raison que lorsque même lorsqu'ils sont
libérés les enfants et qui ont été
enlevés même s'ils ont fait que quelques
heures ou quelques jours ou quelques
heures on reparte complètement
traumatisée et malheureusement souvent
on ne prévoit pas d'accompagnement
psychologique de prise en charge et ses
enfants pourrait être affecté
durablement toute leur vie pour avoir
vécu ces types d'aliments ah c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup de la question
sécuritaire de la lutte contre le
djihadisme dans le sahel notamment mais
s'agissant de boko haram c'est assez
particulier il ya une guerre quand même
mené par avec le nigeria et plusieurs
pays voisins contre 7,7 l'islamiste une
guerre un peu oublié le bilan de cette
guerre et surtout que fait aujourd'hui
le nigeria pour maintenir la sécurité
sur son territoire
oui la fête depuis 2015 là le problème
de boko haram s'est exportée aux états
voisins du nigeria le cameroun le tchad
et le niger de cette façon la réponse du
nigeria sel ne suffit pas les pays ont
convenu
mettre en place une force mixte
multinationales dont l'état major est
basée à dominant avec quatre secteurs un
secteur dans chacun des pays
mais la faiblesse de la coordination
entre les états fait que boko haram
continue de se jouer des frontières de
commettre des actes au niger pour se
réfugier au nigeria il y à cette
faiblesse
et puis il ya une deuxième faible et
c'est le fait de considérer qu'on
pourrait venir au bout à bout de vos
coira uniquement par les moyens
militaires et sécuritaires
il y a un problème de développement dans
le bassin du lac tchad parce que le lac
s'est asséchée et là que des activités
génératrices de revenus qui se faisait
ne se font plus aujourd'hui et du coup
il y a une bonne partie de la population
qui s'est paupérisé les jeunes sont
devenus recrutables évoquera profite
justement de ce terreau favorable pour
continuer à recruter dont il faudra
articuler la réponse sécuritaire aux
questions de développement et il faudra
une meilleure coordination pour apporter
une réponse régionale à un problème qui
est devenu aujourd'hui régionales
malheureusement on a l'impression que
sur le plan de la coordination de la
réponse aux régionales même si il y à
des avancées et reste encore très faible
et la réponse internationale onusienne
par exemple antonio gutiérrez de
patrouille l'onu qui a réagi à une
demande la libération totale des des
enfants encore détenus aux mains de boko
haram est ce que cette communauté
internationale est née elle semble
impuissante
comment l'expliquer oui je pense que la
communauté internationale réagit par à
coups quand il y à un enlèvement
spectaculaire il y à une émotion comme
mon avis avec les filets chiba qu on se
souvient que ça a suscité la
mobilisation internationale avec
michelle obama avec tony blair d'autres
personnalités africaines et après si on
laisse passer et on n'accompagne pas sur
la durée les efforts des pays à la fois
un les aidant à avoir des moyens adaptés
je donne un exemple parce que boko haram
sachant que les pays de la région ont
des faiblesses opérationnelles la nuit
c'est justement la nuit que boko haram
procède à ses opérations dans le moteur
il faut un accompagnement de la
communauté internationale sur la durée
parce que comme on se souvient boko
haram et le mouvement djihadiste le
plus meurtrier au monde avec plus de
quarante mille personnes et les états
doivent être accompagnés ils font les
efforts qu'ils peuvent mais ces efforts
ne sont pas suffisants il faut que la
communauté internationale davantage
on remarque comme vous l'avez si bien
dit d'ailleurs que beaucoup le bassin du
lac tchad est oublié par rapport au
sahel par rapport à aux normes à 10 par
rapport à la région des trois frontières
on sent que l'on considère en occident
que le bassin du lac servent de loin et
que bon c'est une guerre qu'on peut le
laisser entre les mains des pays qui
sont concernés je pense que c'est une
fois sa poche
il faudra que on organise au prendre la
communauté internationale elle
n'accompagne pas parce que en plus de
défis sécuritaires et du défi économique
il ya aujourd'hui une situation
humanitaire désastreuse dans cette zone
d'où je reviens moi même merci beaucoup
à vous c'est dikaba journaliste écrivain
spécialiste des questions sécuritaires
hauteur de co auteurs de cet ouvrage
voyage au coeur de boko haram enquête
sur le djihad en afrique subsaharienne
aux éditions lamarre ton martial